on parle aujourd'hui du pot coeff 3
alors le proco f3 à regarder la
communauté dit pourquoi je crois c'est
un vrai miroir époque of trust voulez
vous regarder pour vous re maquiller et
bien là vous êtes quoi faire alors le
pot coeff 3 c'est un des tout nouveaux
smartphones de pourquoi un tout dernier
smartphone de pourquoi que vous pouvez
précommander oui là en bas la
description il est pré commandable et si
vous regardez la vie de beaucoup plus
tard et bien il est achetable oui vous
avez l'ailier romain description et puis
surtout c'est un smartphone que je vous
offre pas qu'on vous offre avec pourquoi
avec shionogi
et pour ça aussi le lien est en bas dans
la description alors concours à durée
limitée petit vie en main vous cliquez
vous participez et peut-être aurez-vous
la chance de gagner d'être tiré au sort
donc là c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
[Musique]
on va regarder si ce smartphone est bien
il vaut le coup est-ce qu'il vaut c'est
vous est-ce qu'il bossait ou 369 euros
90 soirée version 6 +128 399 euros sur
la version à 8 256 il a un design que
très très actuelle un personnellement
j'aime bien ce que cela fonctionne bien
il ya un grand classique là dessus nous
entre votre module photo là bon après
comme beaucoup de smartphones et bien il
prend les traces de doigts oui les
prends plus plus plus en plus on peut se
regarder coq ou ailleurs c'est un grand
coup qu'on peut parler comme ça c'est
très sympa j'aime bien module photo je
trouve assez bien c'est bien intégré il
est légèrement incurvé sur le côté ça
mange bien on a un petit dos plastique
on a un verre corning gorilla glass 5 à
l'avant donc ça ça fonctionne bien on a
surtout un très grand écran et ça c'est
plutôt sympa et c'est vraiment gros
point que je vais aimer ici vous avez un
très grand écran de 60 pouces c'est un
monstre full hd + alors si c'est une
dalle amoled dalle samsung ça fonctionne
bien c'est sympa 100% des ces ip trois
écrans hd r10 plus bon vous avez un taux
de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz alors
par défaut on n'est pas sur 120 hertz
attention il faut le savoir par défaut
c'est du 60 hertz il faut que vous
veniez vous ici taille vous appuyez sur
100 m ça vous fait quoi elles sont
vertes ça vous apporte beaucoup plus de
fluidité lorsque vous allez venir jouer
à des jeux
autre point qui est positif ici parce
qu'on l'ait sur une machine extrêmement
performante c'est qu'ici vous enviez un
taux d'échantillonnage tactile de 360
hertz vous fera gagner quelques petites
secondes quelques micro secondes lorsque
vous allez lire jouer à des jeux
vous appuyez pas c'est beaucoup plus
agréable c'est beaucoup plus fluide on
voit qu'un très gros travail qui a été
fait là dessus par pourquoi haut niveau
l'expérience de gaming ça c'est
vachement bien
et puisqu'on parle de gueugnon va se
parler de performance parce que très
clairement ce smartphone là il est
taillé il est taillé oui absolument il
est taillé pour la performance
soyons clairs le gros focus qui est fait
ici c'est au niveau de la performance au
niveau du processeur alors c'est super
intéressant parce que on est sur un
smartphone à trois cent soixante dix on
est sur un smartphone à 370 euros vous
avez un processeur qui est plus puissant
que le processeur le plus puissant de
l'année dernière les dernières vous avez
votre dragon 865 c'était un processeur
absolument incroyable quelques jours
très très très actuelle il a été détrôné
fin 2020 par le dernier processeur de
qualcomm qui est le sien dragon 888 et
là vous avez un processeur qui est un
peu entre les deux c'est un sa dragonne
870 5j alors il n'ira pas aussi loin que
le 1 888 mais il ira plus loin que le
865 alors au delà de ses côtés un peu 8
un peu imbitable au niveau des chiffres
ce qu'il faut retenir ici c'est que vous
avez un processeur qui est extrêmement
performant et qui vous permettra de
faire tourner les jeux les plus
gourmands du pectore sans aucun problème
en plus est ce qui est super intéressant
c'est que vous avez soit 6 soit 8 gigas
de ram et la technologie drame c'est
aussi une technologie qui est
extrêmement performant c'est la lpddr2 5
et en termes de lecture et d'écriture
vous avez du stockage en nuage est roi
pendant et ça marche aussi du feu de
dieu donc on a un combo gagnant entre la
rame entre le processeur entre stockage
ou en tout cartonner qui tartinent du
feu de dieu c'est pas ce qui se fait de
mieux mais pas loin et pour voir qu'on
est à 369 euros
et bien franchement c'était vraiment pas
d'écho non et c'est vraiment une super
bien et on pourrait dire ok ça c'est
bien on a de la performance derrière
mais qu'en est-il au niveau de
l'autonomie
soyons clairs on n'a pas ici la plus
grosse batterie c'est vrai quand on
arrive dans les smartphones d'entrée
milieu de gamme le relais sur un très
beau milieu de gamme on cherche toujours
les très grosses batteries 5 mai mais
les empereurs 6000 mis en péril ici on
est sur du 4520 mais les antérieurs on
est donc assez loin des très grosses
batteries de 6000 méliand terrain mais
pour autant et pour autant et c'est là
où c'est extrêmement intéressant et bien
ça fonctionne super bien pourquoi et
bien parce que vous avez un processeur
qui gère super bien l'énergie derrière
qui gère super bien les ressources les
performances et qui du coup va emmener
votre smartphone beaucoup plus loin et
c'est ça qui est super intéressant elle
se produit là c'est que le saint dragon
870 il sait très bien gérer la
consommation d'énergie en plus de sa
besoin d'un truc qui coûte si vous avez
un bloc de charge du 33 watts qui est
inclus mais ce qui est cool c'est que ça
vous le prenez vous laisser brancher une
petite demi-heure d'autres partis pour
une journée une journée me
très facilement donc à côté très
rassurant il ya un côté très pratique de
la recharge en plus ennuyeuse mais c'est
vous avez des hauts parleurs stéréo là
franchement c'est un très très grand
classique vous avez votre première
parleurs qui situent juste là le
deuxième seul haut-parleur vous utilisez
pour vos appels on va avoir une
asymétrie au niveau du signal sonore le
petit haut parleur là est un haut
parleur de renforts c'est ce qu'on
retrouve un petit peu classiquement
franchement au tarif local il est
proposé il ya rien à dire ça fera très
très bien la faire moi qui est
intéressante c'est qu'ici vous n'avez
pas de prise jack alors ça pourrait être
un point négatif sur un smartphone dans
ce segment de prix le fait de ne pas
avoir de prise jack
on est habitués clairement mais ici il a
fallu faire des choix on peut pas tout
avoir donc ici shiomi a fait le choix de
ne pas vous mais trouve sur l'île cocos
de ne pas deux prises jack voilà donc
ici il n'y a pas de prise jack
par contre c'est de nous tous 5 points
pour revenir à péret un casque sans fil
très très facilement pour l'expérience
de gaming c'est top pour venir regarder
des films des séries c'est top pour
venir naviguer sur internet c'est top
après il ya un truc qui est à un poil en
dessous c'est la photo mais une fois de
plus on peut pas tout d'abord si vous
avez pas moins de trois capteurs trois
capteurs on croirait 4 en fait vous avez
trois capteurs vous avez un tout premier
capteur hisser capteur principal c'est
une caméra de 48 mégapixels ouvrage 1.79
celle là qui va vraiment nous intéresser
mon sens l'air tout à l'heure vous avez
juste ici ultra grand-angle de 8
mégapixels touvre f 2.2 avec un champ de
vision sans 19° ok ça marche et ici là
vous avez une caméra de maquereaux
petite caméra de microsoft mégapixels
que vos rêves 2.5
bon là confie qu'elle est extrêmement
classique et sur un smartphone à 360
euros
un peu moins de 400 euros c'est vraiment
ce qu'on va retrouver même sur des
smartphones coûte plus cher on retrouve
souvent ça et jussie ciel avant vous
avez une caméra de celle fille de 20
mégapixels
soyons clairs c'est pas du tout aux
smartphones qui va être optimisée pour
venir faire de la photo c'est pas un
photophone c'est pas le smartphone qu'on
va venir arte pourrait faire de la photo
mais pour autant il est pas mauvais et
il fait le table bien sûr le capteur
principal regarder le monde j'ai zappé
la macro parce qu'une fois de plus pour
moi ça sert globalement pas à grand
chose ici
ce qui m'intéresse vraiment c'est le
capteur principal l'ultra grand temps
les fait venir zoom un peu dans l'image
c'est vraiment que tu es plus
intéressant alors la macro on peut le
faire si on veut se marrer mais voilà
globalement va c'est pas le truc qui me
plaît le plus c'est pas trop trop trop
trop mal on n'a pas le stabilisation
optique donc tout de suite dès qu'on
bouge un peu c'est pardon ça ne pardonne
pas des masses
et ce qui est mon cas moi ça bouge tout
le temps je vais pas 600 l'ultra grand
temps on va perdre un peu en précision
ce qui n'est pas anormal une fois de
plus vous avez de la lumière sans avoir
trop et surtout et bien vous n'êtes pas
de stabilisation on peut venir zoomer en
fois duron
cherche à compenser on le voit ici sur
les personnes et lorsque vous arrivez
jusqu'au faut disent voilà il n'y a pas
de stable c'est pas terrible voilà bon
ça c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
perfectible envoyé qu'un peu moins de
lumière c'est pas où il a un petit peu
de mal avec ces espèces de lumière bleue
là c'est pas naturel c'est poussif la
halle gaulle push un peu trop bon voilà
on va pas non plus demander monts et
merveilles là dessus en extérieur c'est
pas trop mal et c'est pas mal sur le
capteur principal vous allez voir que
sur l'ultra grand temps que tout ça
devient beaucoup plus terne regardez le
rouge de métro là il est ça va c'est pas
mal le ciel on voit bien tous les
détails les armes ça marche bien donc là
ce capteur ici ne va bien il fonctionne
bien et ultra grand-angle voilà il est
terne
il n'est pas dingue dingue au une fois
de plus le pic est pas là mais c'est
normal 370 euros et il a fallu faire
quelques compromis on peut me rouler
jusqu en faut 2 mais on voit tout de
suite et regardez le ici là au niveau
des arbres l'algorithme qui cherchent à
venir compenser c'est pas demain deux
fois 10 une fois de plus on oublie
complètement caméra de cellfish je
trouve assez efficace
on n'a pas d'effet trop poussé poussif
au niveau du du lissage elle est belle
tête de vainqueur là on continue ici en
extérieur capteur principal c'est pas
trop trop mal c'est parce que on va
avoir de mieux mais dans l'ensemble ça
reste assez équilibré ça frôle taf
luttera grand-angle même critique je
trouve pas ça dingue dingue hausse un
peu plus terne c'est moins rigolo il ya
moins de piqué on perd vraiment en
précision mais ça fonctionne quand même
et ça permettra quelques petites photos
et quelques souvenirs surtout sept buts
et dès qu'on se rapproche c'est pas ouf
il a regardé même critique est la
principale on peut on sort des choses
luttera grand-angle c'est pas dingue
c'est vraiment vraiment perfectible mais
une fois de plus sur ce smartphone là ça
ne paraît pas ça me paraît pas normal
la gestion de lumière est pas mauvaise
dans l'ensemble c'est plutôt bien mais
ce que je lui reprochais c'est
effectivement et bien en dehors du
capteur principal aux conditions de
luminosité
on n'a rien de bien extraordinaire bomba
mais une fois de plus on est chez coco
on a une bête de compet et on peut pas
tout avoir donc pour des photos tableau
principal
ok le reste c'est en dessous côte
expérience logiciel on tombe sur un
miroir pour coco ça fonctionne et bien
ici vous à retrouver vraiment tous les
grands
standard alors si vous connaissez pas du
tout vous pouvez y aller les yeux fermés
parce que c'est vraiment très très bonne
expérience logiciel pour venir tout
paramétrer on va tous très très
rapidement voyez c'est très très très
très graphique
rien de bien surprenant reçu vous en
aurez pour votre argent donc ça
assaillants personnellement j'aime bien
la proposition de valeur de ce
smartphone je trouve bien je trouve
performant je le trouve assez complet on
vous aidera en plus du wifi 6 vous avez
de l'infrarouge bon si vous l'utilisez
comme une petite télécommande je pense
pas qu'on soit très nombreux à voir
susan leur dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez mais pour moi je vais pas
utiliser mon smartphone comme une
télécommande chez moi j'ai une
télécommande ça me suffit largement
sinon je peux éventuellement faire appel
à google assistant mais utiliser mon
smartphone comme une télécommande non
j'ai pas est ce que vous le feriez vous
est ce que vous faites est ce qu a un
sens pour vous ou pas marqué le mois en
bas en commentaire vous avez du nfc pour
le paiement dématérialisé notamment
google paye donc ça c'est cool
alors maintenant il ya des choses qu'il
n'aura pas comme je le dis là pas de
prise jack il n'a pas de certification
d'étanchéité donc pas certification
hyper résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière
évitez de mettre dans l'aquarium du
poisson rouge évitez de faire tomber
dans les toilettes évitez d'aller
ramener dans la piscine avec vous mais
s'il rencontre de la pluie ça devrait
quand même bien se passer
il sait pas tout faire ce smartphone et
ce qu'il fait il le fait vraiment bien
si vous devez acheter ce smartphone
c'est que vous êtes à la recherche de
performance de performances brutes et
qui à son tarif c'est à dire 369 euros
90 c'est pas tout faire mais globalement
pas loin c'est compliqué de vous le
déconseiller alors si je vous le
déconseille récit vous êtes vraiment
amoureux de la photo vous voulez tout
parfait au niveau de la photo
mais si vous pouvez un truc parfait au
niveau de la photo et qu'on veut tout
autant de performances
il ya un moment il faut augmenter le
budget voir le le x 2 voies là mais on
ne peut pas tout avoir
tarif toujours être surpris dans mes
tests de smartphones par des choses
comme ça voyez ces petites bêtes là qui
malgré des tarifs qui sont quand même
alors ça reste un budget 1,370 euro très
clairement mais qui malgré un tarif
ultra compétitif vous en propose
beaucoup
et ouais ça fait ça fait pas rigoler
c'était vraiment l'idée de poko dès le
départ pour qu'aux formes sous des voies
plus profonde et sans les regarder
ensemble c'était l'idée d'avoir un
smartphone extrêmement performant et là
une fois de plus il continue à le faire
et ils le font bien
bon voila moi j'aime bien dites moi ce
que vous en pensez vous embarquent
commentaire quand nous on se retrouve
très rapidement pour continuer à parler
tech parler de shiao me et puis
n'oubliez pas un il est à gagner
vous avez le lien en bas dans la
description et puis si vous gagnez pas
et vous voulez vous faire plaisir vous
avez également lire dans la description
il ya plein de bien c'est trop cool à la
libido l'amour y est très vite au cas où